- [Instructor] In 1819, American
author Washington Irving
published a short story about
a man named Rip Van Winkle.
In the story, Rip lived
in a sleepy village
in the Catskill Mountains of New York,
where he spent his days hanging
around the local tavern,
the King George, and avoiding his wife
any time she asked him to
do some work on their farm.
One evening, Rip was
walking in the mountains
when he came upon a strange group of men
who gave him some liquor to drink.
He fell asleep, and when we
woke up the next morning,
he went back into town and found
that everything had changed.
Instead of a sleepy village,
there was a bustling town,
and the inhabitants all seemed
to be loudly debating over an election.
One person wanted to know if
Rip favored the Federalists
or the Republicans, groups
that he had never heard of.
The King George Tavern had
transformed into something
called the General Washington
Tavern, and outside it,
someone had put up an
unfamiliar flag bearing stars
and stripes.
Gradually, Rip realized that
he had been asleep not just
for one night, but for 20
years, and that he had slept
through the entire American Revolution.
Now, this is just a story,
and it's a pretty fun one,
I can't do it justice here,
but I highly recommend you read it.
But this story reveals a lot about
how Americans thought about
the amount of social change
that accompanied the American Revolution.
If you, like Rip Van Winkle,
fell asleep in the British colonies
and woke up in the United States,
which aspects of life
would be familiar to you
and which would be completely alien?
In other words, how much
did the American Revolution
really affect society?
If we set out to answer
this question as historians,
what we're really doing is exercising
the historical thinking skill
of continuity and change.
What changed and what stayed the same
from before the Revolution to after it?
We know that the Revolution
changed the political status
of the British colonies in North America,
which went from being
part of the British Empire
to being an independent nation,
but how big of a deal was that, really?
Was it not much more than
erasing British colonies
from the map and writing
in United States instead,
or did I actually lead to
far-reaching changes in
how people lived?
If we're trying to answer this question,
we really only have three options.
First, things changed a lot.
There was a great deal of change,
and things were very
different after the Revolution
compared to beforehand.
Second, things didn't change much at all.
The Revolution was a
revolution in name only,
and most things were the same afterwards.
Or third, some things changed
but other things stayed the same.
When we're asking what changed
and what stayed the same over time,
we need to be consistent
about the aspects of society
that we choose so that we're
comparing apples to apples.
So, let's decide which aspects we're going
to compare over time.
There are a lot that we could choose from,
religion, slavery, gender roles,
class and social structures,
political institutions.
It's a little like a choose
your own adventure book
for historians.
All right, I'm gonna choose
political institutions,
social structures, and gender roles.
Why am I choosing these?
Well, I guess that I'm interested in
how the ideas of the Revolution,
that all men are created equal
and that government should
represent the will of the people,
played out in reality.
Did the Revolution really
lead to more equality
for men or for women?
Did government really
become more democratic?
So, let's pretend that
we're Rip Van Winkle,
taking a gander at the
society around us before
and after the Revolution.
I'm not gonna go into a
whole lot of detail here,
but if there's anything
you're not familiar with,
just jot it down and
then you can look it up
when you have a chance.
So, what were political
institutions, social structures,
and gender roles like
before the Revolution?
Well, first of all, there
were 13 separate colonies,
not just one single nation.
The colonies were ruled
by a hereditary monarch,
the King of England, and they
had virtual representation
in Parliament.
Colonists considered themselves Englishmen
who were entitled to the
rights of Englishmen.
Colonies had property requirements
and usually also religious
requirements for voters.
Economically, things weren't too bad
for your average white
colonist in the North,
although by the eve of the Revolution,
there was a growing number of poor people
as land become scarcer.
American colonists were
generally better off
than the working class back in Britain.
In the South, however, the
planter aristocracy ruled,
with a handful of wealthy
white slave owners
dominating society and politics.
White indentured servants still existed
in both the North and the South,
although the practice was
becoming a little less common.
Most African Americans,
excepting a few free people
of color in the North, were enslaved
and had no hope of social
mobility, save for running away.
Indigenous people were taking advantage
of the dueling empires
of Britain and France
as best they could, but
after the Seven Years' War,
the departure of France
meant that they were dealing
with Britain alone.
The British government tired
to prevent more conflict
between white settlers
and indigenous people
with the Proclamation of 1763,
which stipulated that the
colonists could not expand west
past the Appalachian Mountains.
Gender roles in the American
colonies mimicked those
of British society pretty closely.
White men did farm labor.
Women cared for the home and children.
A woman had no political or legal identity
apart from her husband in a
practice called coverture,
so a married woman couldn't
own property or vote.
Both enslaved men and enslaved
women worked in the fields.
(yawns)
All this history has tired me out.
Let's take a little rest and come back
to our chart in a minute.
(crickets chirping)
Ah, that was a nice nap.
Hang on, what year is it?
Did we sleep through the
whole American Revolution?
Yikes, let's finish this chart quickly.
How different were political institutions,
social structures, and gender
roles after the Revolution?
In terms of politics, things had changed.
Instead of 13 separate
colonies ruled by a king
and Parliament, there was one nation ruled
by a three-branch government,
where citizens were directly
represented in Congress.
Instead of the rights of Englishmen,
people appealed to Enlightenment
ideas of natural rights,
with protections from government tyranny
enshrined in a Bill of Rights.
Many states reduced or eliminated property
and religious requirements for voting,
expanding the electorate among white men.
Overall, social structures
were pretty similar,
with the exception that the institution
of slavery was being phased
out in northern states,
and the indentured servitude
of whites was being phased out
pretty much everywhere.
In the South, slavery continued.
For indigenous people,
American independence meant
that that Proclamation line
was no longer being enforced
and white settlers saw western lands
as one of the prizes of
victory in the Revolution.
Gender roles also looked pretty
similar to before the war.
Coverture remained, and men
and women continued working
at the same tasks that they
had prior to independence.
One minor difference was
the elevation in the status
of white women, who earned
respect for their contributions
to the war effort as Daughters of Liberty.
After the Revolution, they took up roles
as Republican mothers who
instilled civic virtue
in their sons and also
required more education
in order to properly
inculcate those values.
So, what do we make of these
changes in continuities?
The biggest area of change was going from
hereditary monarchy to democracy,
expanding the vote for white men.
The ideas of liberty and
equality had some impact
on social structures and gender roles,
leading to the gradual abolition
of slavery in the North
and some new opportunities for women.
If I were to answer our question
with one of those three options,
I'd say some things changed and
some things stayed the same.
The Revolution changed
the rhetoric of rights
and expanded democracy for white men
but didn't have much of a
positive impact on the lives
of women, enslaved people,
or indigenous people.
Now, you could choose
totally different aspects
of society to look at and come up
with a completely different take than me.
This is what being a
historian is all about.
If we take care to select aspects
of society to compare across time,
we can answer some tough questions about
how society changed.
Sleep tight.